Who defeated the global jihad? The American military did,
the American soldiers did, with their allies,
fighting in faraway battlefields.
And perhaps, a time will come when they get the rightful credit for it.
So all these factors, and many more besides,
we don't even fully understand some of them yet,
these came together
to defeat a monstrosity as big as bin Ladenism,
the global jihad, you needed this group effort.
Now, not all of these things will work in local jihad.
The American military is not going to march into Nigeria
to take on Boko Haram,
and it's unlikely that SEAL Team Six will rappel
into the homes of al Shabaab's leaders and take them out.
But many of these other factors that were in play
are now even stronger than before. Half the work is already done.
We don't have to reinvent the wheel.
The notion of violent jihad in which more Muslims are killed
than any other kind of people is already thoroughly discredited.
We don't have to go back to that.
Satellite television and the Internet are informing
and empowering young Muslims in exciting new ways.
And the Arab Spring has produced governments,
many of them Islamist governments,
who know that, for their own self-preservation,
they need to take on the extremists in their midsts.
We don't need to persuade them, but we do need to help them,
because they haven't really come to this place before.
The good news, again, is that a lot of the things they need
we already have, and we are very good at giving:
economic assistance, not just money, but expertise,
technology, knowhow,
private investment, fair terms of trade,
medicine, education, technical support for training
for their police forces to become more effective,
for their anti-terror forces to become more efficient.
We've got plenty of these things.
Some of the other things that they need
we're not very good at giving. Maybe nobody is.
Time, patience, subtlety, understanding --
these are harder to give.
I live in New York now. Just this week,
posters have gone up in subway stations in New York
that describe jihad as savage.
But in all the many years that I have covered the Middle East,
I have never been as optimistic as I am today
that the gap between the Muslim world and the West
is narrowing fast,
and one of the many reasons for my optimism
is that, because I know there are millions,
hundreds of millions of people, Muslims like that old imam
in Tunis, who are reclaiming this word
and restoring to its original, beautiful purpose.
Bin Laden is dead. Bin Ladenism has been defeated.
His definition of jihad can now be expunged.
To that jihad we can say, "Goodbye. Good riddance."
To the real jihad we can say, "Welcome back. Good luck."
Thank you. (Applause)